could you please dub me a prison name of
sorts oh it sounds like you have one
already grade races yes my name that's
not how are you hard
great diesel hmm that's valid all right
somebody was mad at you they could call
you a real rat and tomato thank you they
could and then you know what would
happen
guys have you heard feedback from people
that was particularly memorable I've
noticed that there are particular scenes
or seasons or something where there will
be something more vulnerable going on
and more people will come up and talk
about something individual might want to
discuss individual moment samara would
kind of saw a story of just that
overnight you know for all of us like
you know we all like take the subway not
counting but literally just because the
nature of how people consume the show
that is in the first season it went from
just like a normal subway ride to just
people really felt like they knew her
completely
um yet somehow I think our fans are you
know really great in this way that but
at this point it's just kind of I don't
know it just definitely go area
supportive we get like you're like old
friends or something right yeah like
there did you make ID on this tree yeah
hey Piper yeah
you